protestors in Port Saeed determined to
continue what happened in cities
nationwide on Friday night the rare
showed dissent ended when riot police
moved in one officer in Cairo urging his
men not to open fire on demonstrators
demanding the resignation of President
Abdel Fattah el-sisi some arrests were
made including this man in Suez overall
analysts say Egyptian security forces
were uncharacteristically restrained
there was a full night of protests they
were across several big governor it's a
lot of people participated and the
people are just going to be emboldened
emboldened by the fact that they were
able to get away with it that they went
out into the streets they weren't
arrested on mass they weren't shot at so
there's I think there's a significant
chance that this could that this could
build up anger at cuts to food and
energy subsidies has turned to outrage
after corruption allegations a former
military contractor says president Sisi
and military leaders have wasted
millions of dollars of public money on
building palaces luxury villas and
hotels
Muhammad Ali posted videos on YouTube
and Facebook earlier this month calling
for protests against corruption when
most Egyptians live in poverty his
message is resonating with many people
the people are starving my life savings
have evaporated why why does Sisi starve
us while he lives in luxurious palaces
why is he trying to humiliate us he is
supposed to be a public servant working
for us
Sisi he was in New York for the United
Nations General Assembly denies
corruption allegations describing them
as allies Sisi banned all unauthorized
protests after he led the military coup
which deposed president Mohamed Morsi
six years ago tens of thousands of
Egyptians were arrested and jailed in
the government crackdown which followed
Human Rights Watch is calling on the
Egyptian government not to repeat pass
mistakes urging leaders to protect the
right to peaceful protest in upholding
Egypt's obligations under international
human rights law authorities should
immediately release all those arrested
for solely exercising their rights
analysts say it's too early to say
whether the Army's relatively hands-off
response suggests some commanders are
sympathetic to the protest movement
either way they say Sisi should be
worried Victoria Gaytan be al Jazeera